the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of agon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
and A Song of Ice and Fire update video
in this video I want to go over what
George R Martin recently said about
HBO's new Game of Thrones series as I'm
sure most of you already know HBO has
been developing a number of different
Game of Thrones shows based on George R
Martins A Song of Ice and Fire novels
this summer HBO will be releasing their
follow-up season to their incredibly
successful series House of the Dragon
not only that but they're also
developing a new show about the
adventures of Duncan egg it's already
been confirmed that filming will begin
on the Duncan egg series in roughly 3 or
4 months well as if that wasn't enough
already George R Martin revealed HBO's
next Game of Thrones show in his new
update on his not blog website in his
new update he said as it happens HBO and
I have our animated shows in development
set in the world of A Song of Ice and
Fire none of them have been given the
green light yet but I think we're
getting close to taking the next step
with a couple of them when this last
round of development started a few years
back we had four ideas for animated
shows with some great talents attached
writer's room and Summits online and
scripts followed in due course but alas
two of the original projects were
subsequently shelved now for those of
you who read my updates over the years
may recall that I like to say shelv
rather than killed as nothing is ever
dead for good in Hollywood and something
that once set on the Shelf a year ago
can be taken off the shelf a few years
later I still have hopes of presenting
the stories that we sheld in another
form like maybe as graphic novels work
on the other two animated shows
continues however in meanwhile we have
moved nine voyages or series about the
legendary Voyages of the sea snake over
from liveaction to animation budgetary
constraint would likely have made a
liveaction version incredibly expensive
without the show taking place at C and
the necessity of creating a different
port every week from drift Mark to lease
to the ballisk Isles to valantis to Kar
to well on and on and on there's a whole
world out there and we have a lot better
chance of showing it with animation so
now we have three animated shows
underway now will any of them actually
make it to air or happen at all there's
no way to know nothing is certain in
Hollywood but if it does happen with one
or two or all three shows I hope we can
make them as gorgeous and good and
gripping as the blue-eyed Samurai we
will for damn sure try well there you
have it ladies and gentlemen although
this new show hasn't been given the full
green light it sounds like the series
about the Seas snake and his legendary
voyages will likely be the next to
release and while it is unfortunate the
show will no longer be liveaction I hope
the animated format allows for them to
create something that's visually
stunning and maybe even more detail than
they originally had in mind now if it
were up to me I would always go live
action I feel it's a lot easier to
immerse myself and get invested into a
story whenever it's live action with
real actors sets and locations if I'm
being honest I've never really been a
big fan of Animation however with that
being said I would definitely watch
something animated if it were made by
HBO and said in George R Martin A Song
of Ice and Fire Universe although it
might not be my favorite format I'm not
against it either I'll be watching on
release day when and if they ever make a
full series order now I I also hope this
means the sea snake will eventually have
a larger role in House of the Dragon
since they'll likely release an entire
show centered around his life and
Adventures now if you're someone who
follows all the updates and official
announcements from HBO and George R
Martin you know this isn't the only show
they're developing as we already know
they're making House of the Dragon
second season right now and they're
about to start making Duncan eggs first
season and they're still in the
beginning stages of making this animated
show about the sea snake however we also
know they're developing a miniseries and
featurelength film about Egon the
Conqueror and his Sister Wives Indie
wire's article States according to
sources HBO is Keen to move forward with
a series about aegon Targaryen also
known to thron an A Song of Ice and Fire
fans as aegon the conquer whose lineage
extends throughout House of the Dragon
in Game of Thrones HBO and Warner
Brothers may also include a feature film
to tell the story either as a tie into
the series or something else now as you
all know there's also been a lot of Buzz
around the show about Jon Snow and his
life after the events of Game of Thrones
final season as of right now the status
on that series is still up in the air
but we know for a fact they were making
it alongside kid Harrington and his own
team of writers and directors in a
recent interview George R Martin made
another shocking Revelation when he said
him and HBO were developing eight
different shows based on his novels
that's right not six not seven but eight
different Game of Thrones in A Song of
Ice and Fire shows now we might already
know what half of these shows are are
based on what I've already discussed in
the video but they're still working on a
lot of different things behind the
scenes I would love to know what other
ideas they have hopefully one day HBO
will make an official announcement of
their own until then I will let you know
whenever I find out any new information
from other reliable sources now in other
news we also found out HBO will begin
writing season 3 of House of the Dragon
very soon according to redanian
intelligence they will begin writing the
third season at the end of this month
now that doesn't mean they will begin
filming or anything like that but the
writers will begin to flush out their
ideas for where they want the story to
go remember George R Martin recently
said he was locked in the writer's room
for 3 or 4 days he was most likely there
as an adviser giving them ideas and
information that will hopefully help
them stick The Landing I fully believe
they will since the ending has already
been written I am excited to know
they're already working on the third
season and I can't wait to find out
what's happening behind the scenes with
Duncan egg once they start filming in
the next few months as you can see
there's a lot of new and exciting things
happening in the Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire fandom we're a
little over a year away from having
several Game of Thrones shows on the air
at once it won't be long before HBO
starts to dominate the ratings once
again make sure you subscribe that way
you can stay up toate on everything
that's happening with all these new
shows as always I have to thank all of
you for watching another video I hope
all of you have a great day I will see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]
this